der gefälschte urmensch neue
hintergründe in einem der großen
betrugsfälle der wissenschaftsgeschichte
der gefälschte bild down mensch jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction forscher der
liverpool john moores university konnten
weitere fragen der herkunft im fall der
fälschung des bild down fundes
beantworten
der 1912 gefundene bildern mensch setzte
vor über 100 jahren einen meilenstein in
der erforschung der evolution des
menschen zu unrecht aber erklären wir
doch erst mal was es mit dem fund auf
sich hat und was an der ganzen
geschichte erstunken und erlogen war
alles begann
wie gesagt im jahr 1912 der jurist
charts thompson und der paläontologe
antwort gaben damals vor dass sie in der
nähe des dorfes bild down in england die
überreste eines frühen menschen entdeckt
hatten das war eine große sache und die
mutmaßliche entdeckung sorgte für
erhebliches aufsehen in england konnte
bis dato keine derartigen funde
verzeichnet werden die evolution des
menschen wurde um einen vorfahren den er
an propus dort sony urmenschen erweitert
dort sony 1953 flog dann aber alles auf
was draußen und 141 jahre zuvor als
sensation dargestellt hatte entpuppte
sich als dreiste lüge mit hilfe der
radiokarbon datierung wurden die
vermeintlichen evolutionsforscher ganz
schön unter druck gesetzt die kopf und
kiefer fragmente die dorsten und wird
präsentiert hatten waren gerade mal 100
jahre alt mit einem urzeitlichen fund
hatte das ganze also definitiv nichts zu
tun
warum hatten die beiden den fund aber
als einen solchen ausgegeben in einem
von dorsten verfasste schriftstück teilt
der 1909 seinen kollegen mut wird
folgendes mit zitat ich warte noch immer
auf den großen fund doch der kommt
einfach nicht was also eine
verzweiflungstat was ist für die
damalige zeit auf jeden fall war gut
inszeniert denn die forscher berichten
wusste dorsten zitat genau was die
britische forscher gemeinde damals bei
einem missing link zwischen affen und
menschen erwartet ein großes gehirn
einen affen ähnliches gesicht und stark
forcierte knochen
diese erwartung erfüllte er wie die
neuesten analysen der liverpool john
moores university zeigen
schartz thorson ganz schön viel auf sich
genommen um in den kreisen der royal
society aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen
die knochen seien mit chemikalien und
farbe hand behandelt worden um den
damaligen vorstellungen der
wissenschaftler gerecht zu werden
mit hilfe von mikrogramm dna analysen
und vielen weiteren untersuchungen wurde
jetzt die wahre herkunft der bilder und
knochenfragmente geklärt der unterkiefer
gehört demnach zu einem 500 jahre alten
orang utan die zähne sind von einem
schimpansen und die schädelfragmente
sind von drei verschiedenen menschen die
aus dem mittelalter stammen die
konstruktion aus diesen verschiedenen
knochen sei eigentlich auch noch
ziemlich schlecht gemacht worden denn es
wurde zitat immer der gleiche täter
wendet um die zähne in den affen kiefer
einzusetzen
die schädelknochen zusammenzufügen und
um den kies am knochen festzuhalten
der fälscher war kein ausgebildeter
konservator einige aspekte seiner arbeit
sind unfachmännisch und führten dazu
dass knochen brachen gibt so schnell
aushärtet und zähne beschädigt wurden so
die forscher ob dorfen letzten endes
tatsächlich selbst der fälscher war kann
nicht 100 prozentig bestätigt werden
vieles spricht aber dafür
er hätte sowohl die kontakte als auch
das nötige wissen gehabt um die damalige
gesellschaft hinters licht zu führen
abschließend lässt sich noch eines sagen
ausschließlich geschadet hatte diese
dreiste lüge nicht um es mit den worten
der forscher zu sagen zitat die
fälschung des bild down menschen hat uns
eine wertvolle lektion erteilt denn sie
warnt wissenschaftler bis heute davor
sich bei neuentdeckung von vorgefassten
meinungen leiten zu lassen stattdessen
sind gerade dann wissenschaftliche
integrität und strenge nötig zitat ende
wenn er hier klickt also hier kommt er
zu einem anderen video von uns in dem es
auch um eine womöglich vergleichbar
dreiste inszenierte entdeckung geht seid
gespannt wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dann lass mir gerne einen daumen
nach oben und ein kostenloses abo da
dafür einfach hier klicken
was soll s 12 passiert ist dass sich die
gesellschaft hinters licht führen lassen
wäre auch heute noch denkbar
schwerer ist es mit sicherheit aber
nicht unmöglich wie seht ihr das
lass mir eure meinung dazu in den
kommentaren da ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran